bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette petite analyse de séquences
du film jurassic park
évidemment jurassic park que tout le
monde connaît mais il ya certaines
petites choses que vous avez
probablement rater des petites idées des
fois ça tient juste en une phrase des
petites subtilités qui traînent par ci
par là voire même dans le décor est que
souvent les gens qui font des
commentaires sur jurassic park d'un
point de vue pas les anthologies crac
parce que justement évidemment parce
qu'évidemment c'est gros comme un
dinosaure de commenter la qualité
scientifique des dinosaures mais il ya
plein de petites d'autres petites idées
qui sont disséminés dans jurassic park
patil particulièrement dans la première
moitié du film et du coup je voulais
revenir sur ces petites subtilités alors
comme je disais c'est ça peut être juste
un mot ça peut être juste une phrase ça
peut être un élément du décor et je
trouve que c'est des choses qui sont
vraiment très intéressante à voir une
fois qu'on les a vus en fait on dérape
plus alors déjà j'aimerais commencer par
la scène où ils sont dans la salle où il
ya tous les diaporamas qui défilent et
ils sont en train de prendre leur
déjeuner parce que c'est une scène qui
est extrêmement intéressante parce que
c'est là que tout le ton du film se
trouve donc c'est mieux de commencer par
cette scène là que de faire dans l'ordre
chronologique c'est la scène qui fait de
ce film un film anti scientifique et je
sais que ça peut sembler bizarre
en parlant de jurassic park parce que ce
film a justement il ya eu un effet
jurassic park boom
parmi les paléontologues c'est à dire
que un truc comme cinq ans après la
sortie du jurassic park et à une
augmentation il commençait à y avoir une
augmentation du nombre de paléontologues
et cette augmentation du nombre de
paléontologues ne s'est plus arrêté
depuis
donc c'est un film qui a suscité
énormément de vocation de scientifiques
et pourtant c'est un film dont le
message est profondément anti
scientifique
ça se voit notamment dans le fait que
ian malcolm parle de parle de ce qu'a
fait jean à mende comme d'un violent
tout simplement donc il parle du génie
génétique comme da violent et qu'au
final le parc part en couille donc c'est
lui qui a raison
donc évidemment évidemment s'il avait
tort et si tout marchait bien
ce serait pas finalement un film anti
scientifique ce serait seulement les
propos de ian malcolm et qui serait anti
scientifique mais le fait est que le
film se termine mal pour le parc
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya de malcolm
avérée
ça veut dire que les jeux les
généticiens ne devrait pas faire joujou
avec l'adn comme ils l'ont fait alors
évidemment certains me diront que sa
critique autant le côté commercial que
les savants moi je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord je pense qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup de critiques qui vont envers
les savants notamment le moment où il
parle du fait qu'ils se sont hissés sur
des épaules de géants et que du coup il
ne possède pas se savoir je veux dire si
on se met à critiquer le fait d'utiliser
les travaux qui ont été faits avant nous
et d'avancer à partir de ce qui a déjà
été fait autant réinventer la roue tout
de suite je veux dire c'est le principe
même du fonctionnement de la science là
qu'il critique c'est pas seulement c'est
pas seulement l'aspect commercial alors
évidemment l'aspect commercial en fait
partie l'utilisation de pour à des fins
commerciales du génie génétique est
aussi une grande partie de la critique
mais quand même c'est un film qui est un
très fort message anti scientifique
derrière et je trouve ça c'est assez
intéressant en fait qu'il ait suscité
autant de vocations malgré ça etc en
fait la plupart des gens passent
complètement à côté de ce message anti
scientifique tellement on est émerveillé
justement parce que la science a produit
pour ce film parce que je rappelle que
jack warner le paléontologue jack warner
était conseiller scientifique sur le
film et que c'est vraiment grâce à lui
et grâce à la qualité des effets
spéciaux qu'on a réussi à obtenir des
dinosaures qui était plus vrai que
nature
donc finalement c'est la science c'est
la science à travers les effets spéciaux
et c'est la science à travers les
conseils de jack corner qui ont fait en
sorte que ce film soit aussi bon en
grande partie évidemment il ya il ya
aussi le talent d'écriture de michael
crichton évidemment mais voilà ça c'est
intéressant de voir ce phénomène se
dérouler devant vos yeux quand vous
regardez jurassic park ce que c'est une
critique ouverte envers la science et
envers la machine commerciale alors que
ça a été un monstre commercial et qu'il
a suscité autant de vocations
scientifiques faut voir que dans le
livre c'est surtout l'automatisation qui
est critiquée dans le livre ce qui se
passe c'est que le génie génétique au
final ces îles et qu'en second plan la
critique du génie gêne
tic n'est qu'en second plan c'est
vraiment l'automatisation qui est
critiquée et ça ça se retrouve beaucoup
moins dans le film mais justement encore
une fois c'est un des aspects que
beaucoup des gens zappent sais que c'est
pas l'ouragan qui coupe le courant c'est
dennis nedry et pourquoi ça fout la
merde parce que après ça il meurt et que
une fois qu'il est mort plus personne
sait comment redémarrer le film et c'est
là que l'automatisation rentrer en jeu
l'automatisation du parc le on est trop
ils sont trop dépendants de ce que nedry
a mis en place et du coup ils sont
totalement dépendants de nedry en fait
c'est même pire que ça
c'est nedry qu'il qui coupent certains
enclos parce que il va être en retard
pour prendre le bateau et qu'ensuite les
samuel l jackson
donc monsieur arnold décide de couper le
courant
pour redémarrer tout le système ce qui
fout en l'air toutes les installations
voilà c'est même pire que çà mais bref
je m'égare voilà donc dans à la base
dans le livre c'était une critique de
l'automatisation dans le film c'est
devenu une critique du génie génétique
et finalement dans jurassic world ça
finira sur une critique totalement de
l'aspect commercial quasiment totalement
de l'aspect commercial